>> Let's just do a little quiz. So, here is our
concept class and our hypothesis class, which are the same in this
case, which is the set of functions H sub I, that return,
for an input X, it returns the Ith bit of that input.
>> Mm-hm.
>> All right. So if we're talking about
K bit inputs then there's going to be a
hypothesis in this set for each of those
K bits, and that hypothesis returns the corresponding bit.
And so, we're given a training set with examples like that.
And then we need to produce outputs that are consistent with
that. And so what I'd like you to try to figure
out is, tell me, do you think that there is an
algorithm L, such that C is PAC learnable by L using
H? So if you can give me a learning algorithm that
would do a good job, and would, with high probability, be
able to figure this out, then you should go for it.
>> Okay.